[Music]  [Music]  paid dlc courses will be coming to mario  kart 8 deluxe  this is the mario kart 8 deluxe booster  course fast  you may recognize some courses from past  mario kart games  eight courses will be released at a time  over six waves that's 48 additional  courses we plan on releasing by the end  of 2023  courses such as coconut mall  [Music]  choco mountain  [Music]  and tokyo blur will be included in the  first wave  of course you can play these courses  locally and online  [Music]  the first wave of the mario kart 8  deluxe booster course pass will launch  march 18th  pre-orders begin on nintendo eshop  shortly after this presentation  you can enjoy this dlc at no additional  cost with a nintendo switch online plus  expansion pack membership or purchase  the mario kart 8 deluxe booster course  pass on its own